parl de cinéma ce soir juste après tes
PMP direct il y aura Sharon Stone Jin
hman Leonardo Di
Caprio ah ouais mort au vif très fort
très B film sur C8 quand on en a un je
le dis c'est pas tous les jours qu'on a
des films comme ça non mais c'est vrai
voilà donc je le dis voilà on a mis de
l'oseille sur la table et il est là
aujourd'hui voilà donc il a Sharon Stone
elle m'attend là Sharon elle
est après je rentre sur SC voilà
d'ailleurs je l'embrasse Sharon et vous
savez voilà qui a eu un petit
bailone s savez pas vous raconter 100
fois l'histoire quand elle habita en ha
de chez moi oui elle habit en ha chez
habit en ha chez moi au Lila l dans le
93 frère de je te jure tout le monde
l'app Charon boubou à
[Rires]
l'épobre j'embrasse sa famille avec qui
j'ai fait qui pour bravo oui bonsoir
jeis juste dire un tout petit truc en
fait j'aic le cinéma j'avais 17 ans mon
premier film s'appelait moonreaker
et ça ça se tournait dans ce plateau ou
celui d'à côté ou mais je me rappelle
moonreaker c'est il y a pas il avit
pas il y avait requin le gars avec le
gars qui don de requin et B maintenant
c'est
Gill non non il a enlevé les dents mais
il est là il est là dogman ça sort
demain les chéies allez le voir je vous
le dis c'est un grand grand film je me
suis régalé moi j'ai même y retourné ce
weekend voilà je vous le dis je
t'enverrai la photo de de la salle Luc
pour que tu puisses vérifier que j'ai
bien
payé bien
entend on est comme ça on paye et on va
voir les films Luc plus de 30 ans de
carrière combien de films tu penses
faire encore quand tu en as fait 111
films euh produit non en mise en scène
j'en ai fait 20 ouais je sais tu devais
pas en faire 10 au début tu avais dit
j'en ferit 10 oui oui moi aussi j'ai dit
je faisais 10 émissions regarde ça fait
12 ans que je suis là non mais c'est
vrai non mais c'est un truc de fou c'est
au début moi j'étais stressé je te jure
un jour tua dit je feraai que 10 films
et moi j'étais en angoisse tu m'as
angoissé et après tu en as fait 20 donc
là tu vas en faire combien peut-être de
trois encore quoi
arrêteous 6 se c'est fatigant nonrte
arrête non j'ai pas envie de faire un
film de trop pour l'instant c'est pas le
cas bon moi j'ai fait desé missions de
trop mais toi tu as pas fait film de TR
sû mais je te dis est-ce que tu as peur
de l'intelligence artificielle dans le
cinéma euh non non parce que c'est vrai
qu'il y en a plein qui disent ouais
est-ce que ça va pas remplacer les
scénaristes tout ça les scénaristes ont
peur non ça va remplacer une partie du
travail ça c'est sûr
mais en fait le le l'intelligence
artificielle elle se nourrit de tout ce
qui existe déjà donc avant qu'il arrive
à faire un dogman par exemple il va
avoir du mal quoi ouais c'est sûr c'est
sûr par contre pour faire dogman 2 ça va
être pratique je vais appuyer sur un
bouton exactement et tu vas voir si tu
veux que je fasse un chien tu me
demandes je le fais très bien 36
nominations est-ce que tu as eu C prix
est-ce que les prix ça compte pour toi
oui oui bien sûr les mecs qui disent que
ça compte pas c'est des
mythos non peut-être qu'ils sont je sais
pas ouais ça comp tuaimerais tu aimerais
avoir un prix sur ce film parce que tu
c'est c'est vrai qu' voilà très très
honnêtement j'adorerai que lui il en
est parce que vraiment il y a pas il y a
pas de film sans lui ah bien sûr ou et
je je j'espère et je prie pour qu'il en
a il en ait un parce que il probablement
il va partir pour la la course aux Oscar
à mon avis parce qu'il est ouais ça
serait énorme oua tu vas tu vas tu tu
vas aller aux Oscars lui oui et toi tu
as pas passé parce je on voit mieux à la
télé je suis dans le quartier moi euh
non
mais mais sinon je passe avec je passe
une tête tu vois par que je sais non
mais je suis sûr parce que non mais je
connais deux trois personnes là-bas
connaiss c'est qui je connaisaron
Stone non mais je connais de trois
acteurs l Léo tout ça
quoiou DiCaprio vous l'appelez Léo bien
sûr Léo il me regarde il m'adore
j've parle un peu
arabe est-ce que tu es
heureux bonne question de temps en temps
c'est un peu comme le temps je pense il
y a des orages et puis y a du toi tuas
bon on on va pas se mentir de temps en
temps il y a des beau rayons de soleil
donc toi tu as eu des gros orages ces
dernières années ouais enfin beaucoup de
gens ouais je sais ouais je sais c'est
de dire on pouvait pas faire cette
émission sans parler de de voilà de de
ce que tu as vécu ces dernières années
tu as été accusé en 2018 enfin accusé
d'agression sexuelle et de viol par une
actrice et c'est vrai que là en 2018
quand tu apprends ça tu te sens comment
tu dis c'est une blague tu dis quoi non
je comprends pas ouais tu comprends pas
ouais tu vois pas arriver le truc ah non
non vraiment pas non tu te dis ouais
c'est c'est ça Tom dessus tu essayie de
faire quoi tu es tu te dis quoi
qu'est-ce rien parce qu'il y a de il y a
ce qu'il faut c'est essayer de se
recentrer de se dire bah d'abord quand
on est innocent et qu'on a rien fait je
assez rapidement on se dit bon ben il y
a il y a qu'une justice en réalité il y
en a pas plusieurs il y a pas une
justice médiatique une justice il y en a
qu'une donc faut aller se mettre en face
des des policiers en face des des juges
et puis et puis dire la vérité tout
simplement alors ça prend beaucoup de
temps ça prend ouais 5 ans 5 juge ça
prend beaucoup
de mais je dois dire que je suis assez
admiratif de du travail qu'ils ont fait
parce que c'est des professionnel ils
sont pas là pour défendre l'un ou
défendre l'autre ils sont là pour faire
un un boulot ils le font bien et la
police et la justice je sais que souvent
on les trouve
imparfait mais euh toi tu tu as cru en
la justice dès le début je voudrais dire
que c'était une femme avec qui tu avais
eu une relation extraconjugale une
relation que vous avez reconnue que tu
as reconnu concernant les accusations
d'agression sexuelle et de viol il y a
eu plusieurs mois d'enquête comme tu
nous l'as dit cela forcément était
particulièrement douloureux pour toi
puis la justice a ordonné un non lieu en
première instance confirmé en appel et
en juin dernier ce nonlieu a été
confirmé en cours de cassation donc
aujourd'hui
ouais et surtout au départ je suis je je
suis pas mis en examen c'est ça
exactement
art à partir de là donc il y avait pas
d'élément non il voilà c'est ça non donc
mais euh comment tu comment tu t'es
senti lu pant juste à la période o où ça
arrive quand tu es quand tu es pas mis
en
examen c'est on est on est dans une
période où si la la la justice où les
policiers avaient eu ça doute ouais
j'aurais été mis en examen exactement on
le voit dans différentes affaires i
c'est normal en plus qu'on traite ici on
le sait qui a un voilà un élément
forcément un élément important je vous
dis voilà la personne est mise en exam
mais il est quand même bon de rappeler
que accusé ne veut pas dire coupable
exactement voilà juste accusé ne veut
pas dire coupable et surtout on va
revenir là-dessus parce que c'est vrai
que pendant toutes ces années enfin
voilà c'est c'est long mine de rien Luc
on le sait c'est compliqué de travailler
euh voilà quand on est quand on est en
en pleine enquête là-dessus tu tu c'est
toi tu as fait quoi ah moi ça n'a pas
changé grand-chose en fait j'ai souffert
comme tout le monde pendant 2 ans ouais
parce qu'il y a un truc qui s'appelle
covid exactement c'est vrai et on était
tous logés un peu à la même enseigne on
était tous enfermés donc je me suis
recentré sur
l'écriture et mes enfants et ma femme
ouais qu'on a on a renoué tout ça j'ai
beaucoup beaucoup écrit j'ai dû en
écrire 17 je crois ouais parce que
j'adore ça et ça m'a fait beaucoup de
bien en fait je suis très heureux de de
revenir à à mes amours de d'enfance
c'est-à-dire mon petit stylo j'ai pas
d'ordinateur je travaille à la main
ouais je prends mes feuilles de papier
le le plaisir que j'ai eu sa à 16 ans
j'ai commencé à écrire un petit truc qui
s'appelait le 5e élément c'est un petit
truc ouis c'est
sympaou que j'ai réalisé donc je l'cis à
16 ans mais je l'ai réalisé à 32 ouais
donc je suis j'étais très lent au début
ouais ouais 16 ans ça passe pour faire
le 5è élément c'est tellement énorme
mais donc je suis revenu sur sur dans
dans ces années difficiles dont une
grande partie on a tous partagé ouais
c'est ce qu'on a en commun tous cette on
a tout souffert d'une façon ou d'une
autre et beaucoup beaucoup de bonheur à
à repartir sur ce que j'aime
profondément l'écriture ouais c'est ça
donc là tuas tu t'es
dit la mise en scène j'aime bien mais
c'est euh c'est pendant cette période là
que tu as écrit dogman ouais ouais c'est
ça c'était là tu t'es dit je vais y
aller à fond juste Luc à un moment quand
il y a quand il y a ces accusations qui
tombent comment tu fais arrêé c'est que
c'est pour dire à ta femme tu lui dis
quoi c'est combi tu dis voilà j'ai j'ai
fait une faute
voilà le problème c'est que il y a une
partie où effectivement je je ne suis
pas innocent c'est que j'ai eu une
relation extraconjugale donc je l'ai pas
nié alors tu à côté de Jean-Michel mer
ça le choque pas du tout non
non non non mais je rigole non mais
ouais en fait pour il y a un moment
donné pour pour pouvoir dire ça c'est
pas vrai il faut aussi dire ce qui est
vrai bien sûr donc surtout avec sa
famille donc la première partie était
vrai ce que le plus dur c'était surtout
face à mes enfants est-ce que tu as pas
souffert plus pour tes enfants et pour
ta femme que pour toi à la limite euh à
mon avis 10 fois plus ouais c'est ça bah
ouais bien sûr parce que toi je sais que
tu savais voilà ce que tu avais fait ce
que tu avais pas fait tu savais que tu
étais innocent mais tu te dis les mettre
dans une sauce dans laquelle ils ont
rien à voir et les enfants les enfants
c'est terrible parce qu'il d'abord ils
étaient petits
ils avaient une image de l'amour qui
était assez parfaite et ils avaient quel
âge quand ils avaient à peu près le plus
petit avait 10 ouais 10 12 13 et tu sais
que tu casses tu casses l'image de de
l'amour c'est chez tes enfants et ça
c'est ça c'est terrible tu es arrivé de
pleurer comment tu es arrivé de pleurer
pour ça te dire j' arriverais pas à
retrouver l'amour de mes enfants estce
que j'ai réussi à pas pleurer des fois
ouais ouais c'est ça c'est surtout ça
non j'ai pleuré avec sur eux pendant
pendant très très longtemps ta femme
elle t'a aidé aussi à reconquérir aussi
le le cœur de tes enfants j'ai j'ai une
femme exceptionnelle ouais j'ai beaucoup
de chance vraiment est j'ai j'ai rien à
dire elle est
juste mais juste parfaite elle t'a dit
quoi je vais te soutenir je reste voilà
on va on va affronter cette épreuve
ensemble non non mais on a mis plein la
gueule ah ouais ah ouais ouais ou
non c'est pas le genre mais mais il faut
il faut parce que
il faut que faut comprendre il faut
savoir l'amour exactement où est-ce
qu'il est et comment ça fonctionne
donc j'ai appris ça aussi ouais mais
bizarrement c'est très drôle de de
d'apprendre l'amour avec ses enfants
ouais c'est eux qui m'ont appris et
aujourd'hui c'est voilà bah aujourd'hui
j'ai des enfants merveilleux
et ça me rend très heureux ce qui ce qui
m'a aussi fait beaucoup de peine c'est
que je je condamne pas du tout les
médias le le S l'Internet et cetera mais
tu as tes enfants et ta femme qui eux
vraiment non'ont rien fait c'est ça et
alors ça c'est bah c'est ça les médias
internet pour les enfants pour la femme
c'est c'est juste c'est juste un déversi
d'immonde de choses immondes et ça c'est
voilà la présomption d'innocence elle
est valable pour tout le monde hein moi
mais eux aussi
donc ce serait bien de revenir un peu à
une forme un peu plus de de respect
entre nous tous ouais voilà il y a il y
a beaucoup beaucoup d'hommes qu'on fait
vraiment des choses sales et qu'il faut
poursuivre évidemment et je suis à fond
pour euh je suis tu as dit un truc tu as
dit un truc très vrai que j'ai vu tu as
dit attention pour une femme qui m il y
en a 99 qui disent la vérité non il y en
a il y en a je pense qu'il y en a même
plus que ça ouais mais bon qui m il y en
a 1000 qui mentent pas c'est ça ouais
donc mais après le combat il faut que
voilà quand on a un combat il faut faut
partir sur on peut pas partir sur un
combat avec des mensonges c'est pas
possible et puis a suffisamment d'hommes
qui se comportent mal pour pour aller
sur ceux qui le sont vraiment c'est pas
parce que d'un seul coup on
est qu'on a un peu de pouvoir et que on
a 60 ans et que on fait on est une
target parfaite euh ça sert à rien ça ça
se passe pas dans dans les médias
l'histoire l'histoire ça se passe dans
les maternelles voilà faut mettre de
l'argent et aller apprendre aux enfants
parce que c'est qu'une petite fille que
c'est qu'un petit garçon l'ouverture le
genre tout ça il faut ouvrir c'est c'est
c'est là où il faut travailler c'est pas
en allant accuser des gens sans
savoir il y a que la justice qui sait la
justice elle tranche elle dit elle dit
oui elle dit non et il faut la croire
tout simplement Luc tu as tu as tu as
beaucoup d'amis tu as eu beaucoup d'amis
queis dire ENF tu as toujours eu des AM
dans ta vie tu as eu beaucoup d'amis pas
trop pas trop parce que est-ce que j'ai
envie de savoir est-ce qu'on a tous
envie est-ce que tu as eu est-ce que tu
as beaucoup d'amis qui t'ont laissé
tomber bah je pense qu'on a enfin chacun
d'entre nous on a pas énormément d'amis
en fait en ou bien des mecs du cinéma
des mecs qui voilà qui
étaient mais tu
sais je dis toujours que c'est c'est
très très difficile d'être courageux
ouais c'est ça voilà donc il y a plein
de gens effectivement qui c'est pas qu'
m'aiment plus ou qui machin mais ils
font ou là ouais disent oui il y a eu du
recul il y a pratiquement 99 % des gens
qui que j'ai pas vu ah ouais vraiment
quoi qui Tom 99,5 disons non non je te
jure c'est un truc de fou quoi il y a
des mecs parce que je te dis mais c'est
normal c'est c'est pas grave je sais
j'ai beaucoup d'indulgence pour mais toi
tu étais sympa toi parce que moi j'ai
pas d'indulgence tu non non je je c'est
c'est pas grave ah ouais mais les mecs
qui disent est-ce que tu essayais
d'appeler des mecs qui te répondaient
pas ou il y avait plus tu avais moins de
monde au téléphone ah oui ah vraiment
j'ai fait des économies ouais ah ouais
vraiment ah ouais ouais quo
ouais non du coup ça vacner quoi non
franchement c'est c'est ça qui est fou
c'est que tu avais des mecs est-ce que
tu avais des mecs qui étaient tout le
temps avec toi et qui ont disparu du
jour au lendemain ou des mecs voilà là
que tu avais souvent au téléphone non
disons que les les les les les gens que
tu as autour de toi qui te connaissent
depuis très longtemps ouais il y en a
pas un qui a il y en a pas un qui a qui
non mais qui qui est rentré dans le truc
bien sûr ouais ouais ouais quand on me
connaît euh
c'est justement tu ta femme tes enfants
ils ont pas cru un instant non un
instant ça en fait c'est pas ça que tu
avais leur expliquer tu avais plus à
leur expliquer voilà comment bah j'ai
trompé j'ai fait une connerie voilà je
trompé essayer de leur expliquer
pourquoi ouais ouais euh il a fallu que
moi je comprenne pourquoi ah ouais a
c'est je te MS pourquoi bah pour voir
MS non pour essayer de comprendre parce
que j'aime ma femme plus que tout j'aime
mes enfants plus que tout et pourquoi
pourquoi on trahit les gens qu'on aime
quoi mais c'est pas parce que tu as
envie tu as envie de séduireas tu fais
un métier de séduction quand même un
réalisateur un peu ça c'est sûr il y a
mais pourquoi tu as envie de
séduire donc c'est là où le psy est
intéressant parce qu' te ramène à ton
enfance pourquoi pourquoi tu as envie de
séduire par par manque d'amour au départ
tout simplement c'est mais al
sincèrement il y
a c'est pas la peine de de baisser les
yeux il y en a 50 % dans la salle c'est
la même chose
70 ça ça part ça part de là je moi je
suis une famille de de parents qui sont
divorcés qu'on refait des familles
chacun d'un côté et on m'a mis en
pension tu as 14 ans
démerde-toi donc effectivement tu as tu
tu tu as tu es en manque de de
d'affection puis dès que quelqu'un te
dit ah tu es sympa tu es jolie et cetera
tu dis ah bon voilà tu es un tu es tu tu
sais pas comment ça fonctionne
et euh mes enfants et ma femme m'ont
appris à
aimer ils t'ont dit non mais c'est vrai
que tu nous disis que ta femme tuavait
tu avais passé un savon passz le savon
vous avez deux
voà aujourd'huime savonne encore hein
non c'est vrai ouais parce que forcément
quand là on en reparle c'est vrai que je
suis sûr que quand tu rentres tu
reprends une petite Tannée quoi
ouais c'est normal c'est normal c'est le
jeu je ne dis rien Luc le derniè un
trace Luc c'est vrai que moi j'ai je je
connais ça c'est vrai que le monde de la
télé le monde du cinéma c'est voilà
c'est un peu les les mêmes gens qu'on
qu'on fréquente et c'est vra'est-ce que
ça a été plus dur pour toi de monter un
film bon il y a eu le covid tout ça mais
est-ce que voilà les mecs qui disaient
c'est compliqué en ce moment on attend
la l'issue de du procès alors moi je je
me suis toujours dit que la seule
réponse à donner à tout ça c'était la
seule réponse que j'avais donné c'était
de faire un film ouais c'est ça c'est de
répondre avec avec mon art à moi donc ma
réponse la voilà alors justement tu vasy
vas-y excuse-moi mais euh donc le
scénario j'ai pas juste amené un petit
scénario j'ai travaillé énormément et et
c'est vrai que quand j'ai amené le
scénario
euh à Canal plus à TF1 à des partenaires
étrangers pardon beaucoup de pays qui me
suivent depuis 30 ans le film s'est
monté en en 3 jours
wou mais pas pas pour
moi scénario qu'ils ont lu l'histoire
ils ont dit ah ouais d'accord ça c'est
ça on a envie de l'avoir donc ça s'est
monté très rapidement en fait il y a il
y a ma mère qui m'écrit cyil a eu
beaucoup d'amour mais il est toujours
dans la
séduction voilà
on pe on se passe de ses commentaires
non mais je c'est pas une vanne vraiment
elle m'écrit en direct alors j'aiad
justement parce que Luc disait qu'il
avait fait un film voilà pour sortir de
tout ça tu dis avoir reconnu Luc dans le
film oui pour moi il y a une mise en
abîme il y a y a un truc de purgation
des passions moi je vous vois dans le
personnage principal tout le temps en
fait puisquil a abandonné vous avez été
abandonné d'une certaine manière et
aussi bien maintenant quelque part aussi
par des gens qui pouvaient vous aimer
qui vous ont tourné le dos et voilà et
je voulais savoir si vous vous aviez
pardonné ceux qui vous ont tourn le dos
oui tout le monde vraiment tu as
pardonné toi non j'ai aucun problème
j'ai cette faiblesse là elle est humaine
a aucun ressentiment il y a rien du tout
non sincèrement aucun les seules choses
qui peuvent me rendre fou c'est si on
touche mes enfants c'est ça là par
contre je pardonne pas mais voilà pour
le reste non non j'ai pas de pourquoi tu
les pardonnes c'est parce que tu te mets
à le place tu dis que qu'est-ce que tu
aurais fait
toi non moi je sais que je je je crois
être courageux comme garçon donc non moi
je j'aurais pas tourné le dos mais je
comprends qu'on puisse qu'on puisse le
faire en plus le cinéma c'est un métier
ça t'apprend à pas avoir peur parce que
si si tu as peur faut changer de métier
hein ouais bien sûr si c'est comme si tu
es cascadeur début tu joues avec des
sentiments des gens des chiens des
baleines des non si tu as peur il faut
faut pas faire ça ouais faut pas faire
ça non est-ce que est-ce qu'avec le
recul euh aujourd'hui tu te dis c'est
c'est c'est c'était un passage voilà
c'était écrit c'était obligé et
aujourd'hui au contraire je me sens
beaucoup mieux je me sens libéré je me
sens oui mieux maintenant ouais ouais
mieux maintenant vraiment ouais ouais
parce que je suis grâce à ma famille et
et à ces ouais déjà j'ai compris déjà
les mécanismes pour pourquoi on pourquoi
on dérive pourquoi on tu sais c'est très
drôle quand tu es en tu sais ça par cœur
aussi mais non non non non non
mais ce métier en tout cas la gloire les
paillettes et cetera te laisse penser
que tu es plus intelligent que tu ne
l'es que tu es plus beau que tu l'es je
sais que je suis con comme une
he je veux dire c'est que tu tu tu finis
par dire ah bon c'est vrai et en fait
c'est une illusion complète la seule
chose qui te rend meilleur c'est si tu
te lèves un peu plus tôt le matin et que
tu travailles plus sur ton script c'est
la seule chose qui fait que tu seras
meilleur rien d'autre je suis pas plus
beau qu'avant et je suis pas plus
intelligent qu'avant si tu es plus beau
qu'avant ah bon ouais j'ai vu dis dis tu
es de plus en plus beau d'ailleurs je
vais te le dire ça la lum non non non
non j'aime beaucoup j'aime beaucoup il
faut qu'on en parle non non mais
franchement c'est est-ce que à contrario
tu as eu des justement des gens qui
t'ont étonné voilà pendant cette période
tu des mecs voilà des mecs voilà tu t'es
dis lui franchement je croyais pas qu'il
allait être aussi proche de moi et
finalement tu t'es dit il y a des mecs
qui qui en qui tu croyais pas qui au
contraire étaient proche de toi et t'ont
pas lâché non non je P les vrais amis se
sont révélés être les vrais amis en fait
tout simpement pas de surprise he non
non non il a pas eu de les vrais
connards sont veiller les vrais connards
mais c'est tu une question oui il y a
des acteurs qui vous ont dit non Luc le
prochain film sans moi des acteurs
français qui parfois on peut être
véhément avec vous ne m'appelle plus
pour tourner c'est fini qui ont été très
radicaux dans leurs propos ou dans leur
attitude envers vous non faut du courage
pour ça non non non d'ailleurs vous en
avez pris un qui atique qui est un grand
artiste un rappeur et qui joue un rôle
exceptionnel al retourne à Zuric en
Allemagne
[Applaudissements]
toi
juste lu est-ce que est-ce que tu penses
être une victime de De Mitou non non pas
du tout je suis je suis c'est tout à
fait normal que la parole des femmes se
libère et c'est le mouvement est tout à
fait normal il y a pas de j'ai moi j'ai
aucun souci avec ça avec ça je pense par
contre faut voilà faut faut se
concentrer faut être sérieux et
essayer essayer d'éviter un peu cette
espèce de frénésie de folie et cetera
c'est c'est il faut être sérieux sur ce
sujet il faut travailler il faut éduquer
euh voilà merci Luc d'avoir été avec
nous Luc baisson demain doc